el efecto de este reversazo tiene un
impacto en la credibilidad que tiene el
gobierno frente a los mercados y en lo
político en la estabilidad de este
gobierno y además en el futuro de listas
como primera ministra quien completará
apenas un mes en este cargo tras tuvo
que dar la vuelta a la hoja ese
reversazo por una rebelión del partido
conservador del que es jefa porque se
oponen a esa política muy polémica de
reducir la base de los impuestos de los
que más ganan justamente los
conservadores están reunidos en su
conferencia anual en Birmingham en el
centro del país desde ahí esta noche el
ministro de finanzas cuasi cuartel
reconoció que este mini presupuesto como
se le conoce aquí o paquete financiero
causó un poco de turbulencia pero lo
defendió dijo que es necesario el
gobierno trata Esta obra demostrar calma
después de la tormenta pero lo cierto Es
que algunas voces dentro el sentido
conservador aseguran que llegó la hora
de la salida del ministro de finanzas